I have to say that crown looks
absolutely fantastic thank you so much
Conan look it's a it's a media landscape
that's just full these days there are a
lot of bald homosexual fat guys who have
books I'm the one with the flower yes I
know the book soap yourself yeah there
we go see see he's the one with the
flower branding branding very smart guy
very smart and it really really do carry
it off you have an attitude that carries
it off thank you it's called
homosexuality okay guy many things to
say there's a lot of things there's so
many things to say to you guy first of
all you've you've written this book and
as you say it's a crowded market out
there yes you are going I'm not lying
about this you are going all out to get
attention for this book yeah you are
pushing the boundaries you're making
YouTube videos about the book to get the
word out is that right I'm answering
YouTube videos to catch my core
demographics so it's angry irate
feminists women of color people who have
won Tony's and then gay men yeah and for
the video for gay men I tried to get gay
men's attention the only way you can do
that is have go-go boys rub on each
other just rub up against each other
like their chests in swimwear just sort
of getting sexy with each other yeah and
I put it up on YouTube and I tried to
promote it and then after like four
views YouTube took it down because they
said that it was inappropriate content
really yes and when straight people get
all sexy with each other it's just like
a Carl's jr. commercial but when gay
people automatically porn so I got a
little upset about it I did a little
political grandstanding was it to sell
the book mostly but also did I have the
goddess available wherever books are
sold hold up the book yeah there you go
it's good
they go get this pipe shot and every
since the book we go right to one and we
go tight here we go now first of all I
just have a question where do you find
go-go boys how do you just get go-go
boys are you I have lived in West
Hollywood for the better part of 10
years coming are you implying that I
don't know how to source go-go boys
people like I have a number of numbers
in my phone just in case like it's the
Jewish holidays and one of my like
Israeli go-go boys is not answering the
phone because it's Yom Kippur
I've got backups you have level and
Kira's here of go-go boy it's very
difficult Conan because it was the
weekend of pride so those go-go boys
were in high demand yes so I was paying
a top dollar to have these go-go boys
rub on each other so you know when Jack
from Twitter decides that that's
inappropriate that's coming out of my
pocket okay okay all right it can't come
out of the go-go boys pockets they don't
have pockets yeah it's really not now
listen fascinating the book is terrific
it goes back to your earliest memories
what stands out for you is the most sort
of powerful potent early memory like as
a small child I grew up on a little farm
town in Northern California and while I
was growing up there were always old men
who were asking me what do you want to
be when you grow up and if you're
wondering why old men in Northern
California had southern accents you're
going to need to read the book either
this book or The Grapes of Wrath would
always give the normal answer what do
you want to be when you grow up a
waitress
so angry with me they were like I want
to be a football player they were
obsessed with me being a football player
that seems impractical it like it's not
a reasonable way of life you just
thought I can't be yeah well first of
all you do have the size and the
strength to be a football player like
you're a talk show host you've met a lot
of like Michael Strahan is probably here
constantly but most people do not deal
with football players professionally on
a regular basis waitresses however are
all over the place making people's lives
better with pancakes
yeah longer career also I think like
less brain damage from concussions yeah
interesting industry yeah probably about
ten percent less yeah
you